we're back baby cosplay part 2 so we
watched a bunch of anime and decided
that we're gonna go with Sailor Moon
characters pretty Guardians already
sounds like a great band name so we're
gonna just take that literally so it's
like all these strong women we can be
strong women we decided to make our
concept really unique by turning the
Sailor Scouts into men not try and make
fun of it but to have an honest
portrayal of how badass they are cosplay
is all about passion and creativity so
we're taking a lot of our passions and
creatively mixing them together punk
rock 80's glam that's why meet some
dudes cosplay have you seen a lot of
post-apocalyptic 80's glam punk rock
bands Sailor Scouts before when we were
watching Sailor Moon we realized we kind
of fit the character archetypes Zac is a
tiny nerd the big old man you love
shoving food in this big ol mouth Sailor
Jupiter
Ned loves love love love love love
beauty the Sailor Mars because he's fast
she's kind of a [ __ ] I feel like I'm
her already
we just really did not like Sailor Moon
she is very annoying in the first season
we show up with half-assed costumes
people are gonna judge the head of us I
thought cosplay was all like vodcast you
know they make that I'm gonna get
frustrated well I'm ready to do whatever
it takes to make the best costumes in
the history of me ever making the
costume we're gonna need some help the
try guys try cosplay episode 2 the try
guys make Sailor Moon costumes
I mean Linda Lee and I am a cosplayer
something like this took me about seven
hundred hours what are the basic things
you need when you start construction
generally we use like things like worbla
at least know how to sew a straight line
hot glue is really great for our phones
yeah hot glue you guys should definitely
feel some pressure all right let's do it
all you need to start patterning your
tiara you cut out your shape and you get
this madam Jupiter perfect dude dude
dude no then you start cutting out
is a very basic cosplay accessory that
anyone can make no trace
just trace you already get up this is
already not fun hot glue the raised
detail hahaha it doesn't have to be
perfect oh that's a lot of extra when
that's all done I'll have your base
carrot our energy was waning so we
thought boobs would help so now it's
time for actually constructing your
tiara for people that don't know what
worbla is it's a thermoplastic with heat
what happens to it it gets really soft
almost like that tiara ravioli kind of
heat it bend to my submission pasta
plastic you don't want to heat it too
much you said we were good turn it off
and then you're gonna take the second
piece on top I've got a mustache I know
we're doing better than Mercury and
Venus so as you can see it's already
coming out can I give you an Asian
household experience no yeah I do better
okay I'm a planet girl we're gonna
awesome at this in cosplay the sexiest
thing is confidence know if you're
wearing your costume and you're really
proud of it and you feel really badass
it kind of shows in the way you stand I
guess pick yeah
hey stage yeah yeah it's really cool
when you see guys as Sailor Moon
characters
yes empowering for women she's the first
you know superhero out there one of the
first ones for girls and it's all about
different types of women tall as I
usually am I always got made fun of when
I was younger but it just gave me
strength to be me so it's being yourself
in a team that helps you win the day so
now we're actually gonna start making
the Sailor Moon bows I can honestly say
I've never made a bow in my life that's
a version of a bow in college like on
winter breaks and stuff I sit around and
while we were all hanging out I'd just
be sewing but that's what like lonely
weird people do about the process know
what's about the end product so when
she's cutting out the pattern I'm going
to be threading the needle whoa
my mom taught me how to sew go along
baby you pop it slice it and then you
slide it boom that's your knot that's
all you need but yeah there is a needle
needle
I would trace it first so you do that
I'm gonna try this technique are you
already selling yeah I like it
and when you're a hand sewing you want
to make sure that you're gonna be sewing
in between these like this framework
right here then get enough string for
that boom all right this is gonna take
too long you want to abort the hot glue
then we close opening with the whip
stitch am I doing this whoop stitched
correctly probably not how do you know
where you're poking through oh there it
is glue is really a good way to do it
because then it doesn't take much time
and you can go make a burger instead and
then when you turn it inside out look
you have sleeping masks done I see I
can't believe I've been doing this for
like an hour to have so many injuries
out fold the center
to create the pleats I made a bowtie for
a mouse one look and all you do with the
ribbon is tie it right in the middle and
wrap it that way
okay look mistakes for me really proud
that I made it myself that's what
matters
also we got the authentic experience cuz
our clothes are off I mean this stuff is
really meticulous this must take forever
for someone to make an entire costume
this chaos was fun but if we're gonna
bring the goods to Animax we're gonna
need to take our time we got a lot of
work together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're Eugene and Keith better at making
bows than us me but we'll be better at
ribbon dancing you tell us